c'est un des produits phares de la pme
automation 2000 le dg pt 2 un dispositif
d'alerté de sécurité pour les
transformateurs électriques dans cette
entreprise 10 salariés ont bénéficié
d'une prime de 1000 euros fin décembre
2018 le seuil maximal de la mesure
annoncée par le président de la
république fin décembre ça nous a bien
aidés tout à fait je suis tout seul
c'est très dur payer loyer un mot j'ai
heureusement que je travaille ici quand
même
et cette prime ça ne va pas ça nous
permet par exemple d'y aller en vacances
ces employés sont éligibles car gagnant
moins de 3600 euros par mois au total la
société a versé 10 mille euros au lieu
de quatorze mille euros grâce à la
défiscalisation que j'estime que les
salariés le mérite de toute façon je
pense que c'est important le pouvoir
d'achat c'est un sujet qui travaillent
tout le monde au quotidien et les
entreprises aussi petite soit elle
doivent essayer de participer à l'effort
même situation à la clinique de l'europe
de port marly un établissement privé de
260 lits il emploie 400 salariés 75 % du
personnel a bénéficié d'une prime de 200
euros soit 377 employés on l'a eu
rapidement souvent on voit d'abord le
versement sur le compte qui arrive donc
on voit que c'était pas prévu travail et
un week-end sur deux de 8h à 20h vous
avez une vie de famille vie sociale pour
1300 euros 1400 euros
non pour moi je pense que la prime ça
fait plaisir mais c'est tendu
il nous a semblé important de donner une
infinie de reconnaissance à nos salariés
qui a dépassé l'année auprès des
patients ils font tous un métier
difficile
cette disposition est prévue par la loi
du 24 décembre 2018 les entreprises ont
jusqu'au 31 mars 2010 9 pour utiliser
cette réforme